so it looks like the 3d play gets moved
past our world through the Wardrobe and
is now infected Narnia The Chronicles of
Narnia the voyage of the Dawn Treader
title is quite a mouthful so we're back
in Narnia on a boat called the Dawn
Treader along with Lucene Edmund they're
back the other brother and sister
they're not because as as Lance said in
the last movie they're too old to come
back now they pretty much got to deal
with a much harsher and much more brutal
world of reality
apparently Narnia has the neverland
ranch gauge to come back you cannot be
taller than that to come back and Lucy
and Edmund have brought their cousin
Eustace I think that's how you say his
name Eustace is pretty much a punk who
hates everything and gripes about more
is one in every family
but now adventure and Narnia and hey
alright now we all love The Lion the
Witch in the wardrobe because we were
attached to it if you ever went to
school like any kind of school you read
The Lion the Witch in the wardrobe you
had that nostalgia tethering you to it
and it actually was a pretty solid movie
the sequel Prince Caspian no one read
that book current a few people did but
it wasn't like The Lion the Witch and
the Wardrobe when you think Narnia you
do not think Prince Caspian and so less
people cared about the movie so now
enter the voyage of the Dawn Treader and
it actually wasn't that bad it's pretty
good in this movie Prince Caspian and
his crew were sailing to the far reaches
of the Narnian waters and they stopped
on these islands and every island is
different than the last island I thought
it was a good way to add variety to the
movie and that one part in the movie the
evils like all around and they're like
don't let the evil into your mind don't
think of anything it'll become that and
then someone thinks of something and
you're like I couldn't help it it just
popped in there I was like if the Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man
Trump's onto Narnia this is getting an
awesome tacular like right away and the
addition to the punk cousin as much as I
thought it'd be forced and I wouldn't
like it it actually worked for the movie
even though he seemed like a bit of an
over actor who's like no we're good to
go now I don't wanna be how usually
movies have a character like that so
they can learn their lesson and become a
better person by the end but ultimately
it's all crap you don't care this movie
actually surprisingly did it well I
cared about him becoming a better person
and I cared about his relationship he
builds with Reepicheep yes I know the
mouse's name and the climax in this
movie was really exciting all the stuff
that a fun cool movie should have this
kind of genre and the ending of this
movie was actually really touching and I
knew it would try to be but I thought
just gonna be like snore come on let's
move upon man that donkey kong country
is not gonna play itself
let's go but it was good it did its job
it surprised me I mean if you don't have
a heart don't watch it not that I have a
heart I'm just saying I don't I'm
hardcore
I'm just saying it'd be like a guy with
no taste buds eating a lot of candy I
mean what's the point so the movie
starts out a little rough I mean you're
not sure where it's going you're not
even sure you give a crap but about
halfway through really finds a snitch
and you end up liking it I would say if
you're not the Tin Man you would buy
this movie even on blu-ray or it's at
least a good time no alcohol required I
mean it's good family entertainment
that's a lot better than Prince Caspian
was voyage of the Dawn Treader made me
like Narnia again also that the thing I
hated about this movie is in 3d and not
the whole like you know filmed in 3d
upper class 3d now so if you're gonna
see it see it in 2d because the 3d just
hurt my eyes but if you'd like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more
[Music]